à paris l'assassinât d'une vieille dame
de 75 ans inquiète les policiers et les
habitants du xviiie arrondissement car
c'est la septième fois en un mois qu'une
personne âgée est tué pratiquement dans
les mêmes conditions
la police pense que le ou les agresseurs
remarques leurs victimes quand elles
font leur marché dans le quartier les
suivent et ensuite les bouscule devant
elle et pénètre chez elle pour les voler
plusieurs dames seules et âgées ont
trouvé la mort de façon violente depuis
un mois dans un périmètre de 400 mètres
autour de la butte montmartre à la
police enquête pour l'instant elle ne
semble pas posséder d'éléments
véritablement significatif au delà des
polémiques qui ne manque pas de
ressurgir comme toujours en pareil cas à
propos des mesures de sécurité dans ce
quartier de paris il nous a semblé utile
d'aller voir aujourd'hui d'un peu plus
près ce qu'en pensait sur le terrain
l'enquète de béatrice berge lundi 60
boulevard de clichy yuna ces gars kyo 71
ans est assassinée mercredi alice
benhaim 84 ans est retrouvée morte au 15
rue marc seguin à deux pas de là jeudi
77 rue pajol c'est marie choix 75 ans
qui tu es hier vendredi enfin maria
mikko diaz 75 ans est poignardé au 27
rue des trois frères 4 vieille dame
assassinée cette semaine sept depuis un
mois dont cinq dans le xviiie
arrondissement
de quoi faire froid dans le dos à la
population si vous avez peur
de quoi
on n'a plus peur
écoutez c'est pas très rassurant j'ai
quatre vingt deux ans j'ai pas peur
parce que j'aime me dire que si jamais
ils viennent à la maison ben oui tu as
reçu
premièrement parce que j'ai un chien et
deuxièmement je suis pas manchot tc5 on
peut pas fait c'est ap on n'a plus la
force quand je commençais à me dire
c'est ça mais ça ne fait rien il faut
pas avoir peur quand même on les aura
pas si effrayé que ça nous vieille dame
la peur la colère c'est vrai que les 18e
et sensible c'est l'arrondissement le
plus peuplé après le 15e il est aussi en
deuxième position pour le nombre de
vieillard c'est vrai encore que le 18e
s'est pigalle barbès la goutte d'or avec
ces concentrations d'africains de
maghrébins et de jeunes pas toujours
très nettes mais c'est aussi montmartre
et l'avenue junot c'est vrai enfin que
quatre assassinats la même semaine dans
le même quartier c'est beaucoup trop
pour une simple coïncidence mais
actuellement rien ne prouve que le ou
les coupables soient des voisins
immigrés ou drogué
ça peut être des noirs mais ça peut être
nous ça peut être davantage
mais
au niveau
des jeunes que je connais et parce que
le japonais non parce que je fréquente
écarté au camp
je vois pas comme ça
toutes les suppositions sont permises en
attendant les résultats de la police
judiciaire sur place les îlotiers
assurent leur travail de routine en
jonglant toujours avec leur peu
d'effectif curieusement ce septième
assassinat d'hier n'a pas déclenché
d'avalanche d'appel au commissariat
local c'est la presse qui se déchaîne et
pas la population quant à nos grands
mères du xviiie elles continuent leur
chemin parfois avec humour
vous savez ce qu'on va faire on va faire
un défilé avec des pancartes
mais
enfin ce matin on a retrouvé assassiné
dans son appartement du 12e
arrondissement madame germaine cohen
tannoudji madame germaine une dépêche
tombe le 5 octobre une vieille dame a
été assassiné la veille une brève à fr3
une autre femme et tués le lendemain une
troisième le 9 octobre ont leurs lattes
en pages intérieures du parisien c'est
encore à l'époque qu'un fait divers
presque banal lorsqu un mois plus tard
le 9 novembre d'amico diaz est assassiné
c'est la septième victime la quatrième
depuis le début de la semaine dans le
xviiie arrondissement
la presse se précipiter le lendemain
samedi ces assassinats en série s'étale
à la une ouverture des journaux écrits
ou audiovisuels
l'arrondissement de la mort le 18e a
peur quelques journaux titrent samedi
sur le fondement de la population sur
place pourtant les grands-mères gardent
leur sang-froid
on n'a pas peur
on a
écouté c'est pas très rassurant
non j'ai pas peur il pas danger 82 ans
j'ai pas peur parce que j'aime mieux
vaut dire que si jamais ils viennent à
la maison ou bien été reçu avec même
parce que j'ai un chien et deuxièmement
je suis pas manchot
lundi dernier on retrouve une 6e puis
une septième vieille dame assassinée
dans le xviiie neuf victimes en tout la
tension est à son comble à
la tête de marc perrone actionnaire mais
tous ces personnages et les moeurs
la presse du lendemain mardi traite
largement la sphère le débat s'élargit
se politise si certains journaux replace
l'information en pages intérieures
d'autres la traite à la une de plus en
plus largement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les arrestations dans la sphère
des pommes et l' enquête sur les
assassinats de personnes âgées à paris
sont bien sûr les deux titres essentiels
de ce journal daté du 13 novembre 84 ce
matin fait grand-chose de nouveau
officiellement dans l' enquête mais
beaucoup de choses en revanche dans les
journaux un dessinateur du parisien
dresse même le portrait robot du tueur à
partir du témoignage d'une vieille dame
anonyme la majorité des quotidiens
proposent deux grands dossiers sur la
sécurité de longues interviews chaque
journal alimente les débats
selon bien sûr son genre et sa
sensibilité politique à paris dans le
18e arrondissement l' enquête se
poursuit pour retrouver l'assassin des
vieilles dames aujourd'hui 2000
personnes âgées sont venus à la mairie
c'est le maire udf de l'arrondissement
roger chinaud qui les avait conviés pour
annoncer les mesures mises au point afin
d'assurer leur protection
s'il ya urgence appelez-le 2 123 92 00
tous les jours douze personnes toutes
bénévoles recevront les appels entre 8h
et 21h
c'est une des mesures annoncées cet
après midi au cours d'une réunion qui
regroupait les élus locaux du xviiie la
police et les personnes âgées
pendant une demi-heure plusieurs
milliers de personnes ont reçu des
conseils et a pris la création d'un
nouveau service protection troisième âge
18e désormais les personnes âgées
pourront sur simple appel se faire
accompagner et transporter gratuitement
pour aller à la poste ou à la banque
d'autre part monsieur chinon le maire du
xviiie a annoncé que les personnes âgées
pourront bénéficier gratuitement par
l'intermédiaire du bureau dette sociale
de verrous deuil dont et d'autres
bailleurs de portes à l'entrée de leur
logement encore deux vieilles dames
découverte assassinée aujourd'hui cela
fait 6 6 en moins d'un mois avec à
chaque fois d'étranges ressemblances
entre les meurtres comme si l'assassin
avait attendu les vieilles femmes sans
méfiance mais surtout on craint
maintenant la reprise d'une psychose du
genre de celle qui s'était développé
l'année passée après une autre série
d'assassinats dans le xviiie
arrondissement de paris le reportage de
rachid arhab et marcel martin
ce matin dans un petit immeuble sombre
du 12e arrondissement
ces deux vieilles dames essaye de
comprendre ce qui est arrivé à leur
voisine madame vendôme 82 ans ancienne
bibliothécaire du louvre retrouvée
assassinée chez elle la mort remonte à
plusieurs jours
personne ne s'inquiétait dans l'immeuble
de ne pas la voir ben c'est à dire moi
je m'en suis inquiétée lundi vous savez
à mon âge j'ai pu penser c'est un métier
que quand la dame m'a demandé d'aller
voir pour lequel paye son loyer alors
j'ai frappé on n'a pas répondu bien sûr
si vous êtes agressé alors ses économies
vous savez savoir si avec des économies
ça j'en sais rien parce qu'elle n'était
pas on ne la voyez pas
madame vendons a visiblement été
étranglées par quelqu'un qui l'aurait
suivi jusqu'à son domicile l'assassin
chercher certainement des bijoux et de
l'argent
même scénario hier dans le 5e
arrondissement
une dame de 75 ans est étranglé par
quelqu'un qui fouillent complètement son
appartement dans les deux cas il n'y a
aucune trace d'effraction sur les portes
d'entrée d'étranges ressemblances avec
quatre autres assassinats de personnes
âgées commis très récemment à paris
trois des victimes habitaient dans un
rayon de moins de 400 mètres autour de
l'église d'alésiens
qu'ils aient un lien entre eux ou pas
ces crimes rappel la série d'assassinats
de vieilles dames l'an dernier dans le
xviiie arrondissement des crimes jamais
élucidé qui avait engendré une véritable
psychose et une sérieuse polémique sur
la sécurité c'est grâce à la présence
d'esprit et surtout vous allez le voir à
l'obstination d'un commissaire de police
que les tueurs des vieilles dames sont
ce soir en prison depuis plusieurs
années le commissaire jacob c'est son
nom épluché toutes les synthèse de la
brigade criminelle et de la brigade de
répression du banditisme
un véritable travail de fourmi
matérialisée par une fiche signalétique
stipulant que le tueur était d'origine
martiniquaise qu'il portait une boucle
d'oreille et qu'il était souvent coiffé
d'un béret imaginez la surprise du
commissaire jacob quand fortuitement sur
le trottoir il se trouve face à face
avec un homme qui correspond trait pour
trait au portrait robot emmanuel vanier
va vous raconter la suite
11 dames âgées assassiné thierry paulin
c'est peut-être le plus grand criminel
de toute l'histoire judiciaire française
11 vieille dame assassinée est toujours
la même méthode il filait ses victimes
jusque chez elle ils les torturer pour
leur faire avouer où elle avait caché
leur économie et puis ils les tuent et
en les étranglant depuis octobre 84
toutes les polices de paris était à ses
trousses signalement origines
martiniquaises 25 ans environ rien de
bien précis et puis tout récemment une
dame âgée une rescapée fourni deux
détails clés le tueur porte une boucle
d'oreille et une casquette détails qui
sont communiquées à toutes les polices
d'autant plus que les agressions ont
repris depuis quelques semaines au
commissariat du 10ème arrondissement
le commissaire jacob a suivi toute la
sphère hier après midi à quelques pas de
là il rencontre un homme qui correspond
exactement au signalement diffusé
arrestation immédiate sans aucune
difficulté sa réaction était un petit
peu surprenante il a été vraiment des
routes et il n'a pas réagi ça s'est
passé très très calmement
fuir
bon jeu mais fait un petit peu mais il
n'a pas cherché à fuir et
et m'accompagner au juste au
commissariat ou à ce moment là bas il
fait il a demandé ce qui se passait
désirant voir un avocat a immédiatement
repris au commissariat il a désiré voir
un avocat thierry paulin est transféré
au quai des orfèvres l'analyse de ces
emprunts tu ne laisse aucun doute c'est
bien le meurtrier du xviiie depuis trois
semaines et thierry paulin vivaient ici
en plein centre de paris un client
gentil disent les hôteliers il a déjà
avoué onze meurtres et une vingtaine
d'agressions il a même donné un complice
jean thierry mathurin auteur de deux
autres assassinats ce soir les deux
hommes sont toujours gardés à vue et
dans le xviiie arrondissement
c'est la fin de trois années d'angoise
madame monsieur bonjour un jeune homme
soupçonné du meurtre de plusieurs
vieille dame a été arrêté hier par la
police parisienne thierry paulin âgé de
24 ans a avoué avoir assassiné 11
vieille dame cet dans le xviiie
arrondissement et deux dans le 14ème des
meurtres qui remonte à octobre 84 et
janvier 86 et ce matin deuxième
arrestation le clos le complice de
thierry paulin a été arrêtée eric
tréguier
oui j'ai tué onze fois oui je reconnais
20 agression terrible thierry paulin le
tueur de vieilles dames est passé à
table ce matin sur les onze meurtres il
en a reconnu sept dans le sol xviiie
arrondissement et deux dans le 14ème
voici les noms de sept des onze vieille
dame le mobile toujours le même l'argent
un argent facile des personnes sans
défense qui l' assassiner sauvagement
déjà arrêté il ya quelques mois à
alfortville pour violences et
infractions sur les stupéfiants
celui qui avait mobilisé toutes les
polices de la capitale a été reconnu
grâce un portrait robot diffusé depuis
quelques jours francis jacob dit la
foudre commissaire dans le xviiie avait
justement ce rapport dans la poche sur
les circonstances le récit du
commissaire j'étais en train de
converser avec des commerçants du
quartier sur le trottoir à cet
emplacement et lorsque c'était lorsque
le l'individu en question s'est présenté
à quelques mètres du groupe bon sens au
signalement correspondant à celui
diffusé
j'ai procédé je lui et j'ai procédé à un
contrôle d'identité
portrait robot et empreintes digitales
les aveux de thierry paulin ont déjà a
permis l'arrestation ce matin d'un
complice jean thierry mathurin pour
thierry pour le meurtrier des vieilles
dames on en est ce soir à 21 crime avoué
18 inculpation du côté des enquêteurs et
de l'identité judiciaire on déplore un
petit peu qu'il n'y ait pas une
informatisation centralisée des
empreintes digitales car poulain avait
été arrêté deux fois dans le passé à
alfortville et à toulouse sans que l'on
fasse à l'époque de rapprochement entre
lui et la série de meurtres parisien
quant aux personnages de ce meurtrier
nous allons l'évoqué dans un instant
avec un psychiatre le docteur charles
nicolas mais auparavant l'anc est utile
de voisinage daniel wolfromm
le type même du jeune branché thierry
paulin les cheveux colorés l'anneau dans
l'oreille un jeune homme sympa qui
fréquentent les halles comme tous les
jeunes de son âge un tueur hors du
commun thierry paulin 21 assassinat de
vieille dame peut être plus massacrées
souvent de manière ignoble les gens qui
l'ont côtoyé n'en reviennent pas eux
aussi
oui
bien sûr que je veux
il dit lui même acheté des vêtements
oui je sais très bien qui sait il
s'éteint mais je vais en blanc derniers
temps ouais c'est ça
je sais
ça mais en plus c'est aux rondes
il était vachement dégagement aux
antilles et tous sympas face à l'attenté
de nos m'acheter des caleçons
ne semblait pas drogué ce qu'il n'ya pas
plus que pas plus que d'autres
aujourd'hui non pas du tout
drogué peut-être pas thierry paulin
noctambules sûrement un danseur de
casion fasciné par la grande ville et le
strass une fois de plus un portrait à
milieu de tous les clichés habituels sur
les tueurs fous à paris escalade dans
l'horreur l'assassin des vieilles dames
qui a été arrêté hier aurait commis 21
meurtres
grâce aux empreintes ya plusieurs
détails particuliers thierry paulin 24
ans a été confondu c'est l'aboutissement
de trois années de travail aujourd'hui
ceux qui connaissaient paulin ne
comprennent pas certes paulin est un
marginal mais rien rien dans son
comportement ne pouvait éveiller les
soupçons patrice pollet
au quai des orfèvres depuis maintenant
24 heures pour l'un parle aux
inspecteurs d'une voix calme sans
émotion il raconte ses moeurs 21 à
l'heure actuelle dont 18 vérifiés par
les policiers jean-thierry mathurin
l'ami de paulin a reconnu lui avoir
participé à sept de ces assassinats
gagné domicile de paul ince et hôtels du
1er arrondissement deux étoiles 400
francs la nuit est ici paul a donné
l'image d'un jeune homme à la vie sans
reproche en gagner pas mal d'argent
facilement
c'est quelqu'un de facile
alors bon d'après ce qu'il avait dit fin
du 6 9 10 et le gagner donc en
travaillant puisqu'ils étaient branchés
dans des boîtes de paris à ses célèbres
qu'ils organisaient des soirées
étaient aussi disc jockey qui devrait
que d'enquêté très bien payé pour ça et
qu'ils étaient bien branché dans les
milieux gérer leurs dons du showbiz si
on peut dire enfin vous voyez ce cuir la
nuit quoi vous pouvez pas imaginer en
tout cas qu'il pouvait être un meurtrier
un toxicomane whippet en france le dira
séparation énorme surprise mais
meurtrier oui ça c'est vraiment
surprenant avec 21 meurtres avoués pour
l'un ce soir en place parmi les plus
grands criminels de droit commun de ce
siècle en france il dépasse de loin
landru et n'est plus très loin du record
du docteur petiot guillotiné en 1946
pour avoir tué 24 personnes pendant
l'occupation
l'effarante odyssée criminelle de
thierry paulin inculpé pour l'instant de
18 assassinats de vieille dame mais qui
en a avoué déjà 21 je regrette à
certains moments que la peine de mort
n'existe plus et qu'on ne puisse plus
l'appliquer a déclaré le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur charles pasqua on
n'a évidemment pas fini de s'interroger
sur la double personnalité de ce garçon
de 24 ans qui avait plus tôt dans la vie
courante les apparences d'un petit
délinquant banal jean françois grégoire
voici le visage de thierry paulin
meurtrier à la monstrueuse désinvolture
ce jeune garçon souriant sympathique
d'après les témoignages des gens qui
l'ont connu mener la vie facile plein
d'insouciance
un jeune homme branché je suis un acteur
a même déclaré un policier
irrésistiblement attiré par les strass
du showbiz trop haut pour lui la fête la
drogue et les amis pour qui rien n'était
trop beau samedi soir autour tour paulin
réunissait 50 personnes autour de lui
pour son anniversaire à ses frais carton
d'invitation à l'appui une note de 15
mille francs régler trois semaines
auparavant liquide avec l'argent de sa
dernière victime c'est avec un
effroyable sang froid que thierry paulin
a énuméré tous ces meurtres lui qui
allait tuer des personnes âgées sans
être en proie au moindre doute à la
moindre hésitation mais toujours avec
une lucidité démoniaque je ne m'attaque
est qu aux plus faibles at il avoué
quand l'une d'elles me paraissent est
moins vulnérable
je laissais tomber le procès de thierry
paulin n'aura sans doute jamais lieu
celui qui avait reconnu une vingtaine
d'assassinats de vieille dame est
aujourd'hui à l'hôpital dans un état
désespéré éric meunier
thierry paulin et depuis hier dans un
état désespéré à l'hôpital bichat il
souffre d'une maladie incurable sans
doute le sida on savait en effet que le
tueur de vieilles dames présentait une
séropositivité avec complications le 1er
décembre 87 jour de son arrestation à 26
ans thierry paulin était tristement
entré dans l'histoire aux côtés des
londres-- petiau il était accusé de 18
meurtres de vieille dame assassinée à
paris entre 84 et 87 et puis la mort
aujourd'hui de thierry paulin meurtrier
présumé de 18 vieille dame à paris entre
1984 et 1987 oui il est mort du sida
arrêté par azor thierry paulin avait
reconnu les faits des faits terrifiant
qu'il associe ainsi à l'une des plus
grandes séries de crimes du 20e siècle
clément weill-raynal
une série de photos restera dans les
mémoires celle de thierry paulin le jour
de son anniversaire dans une boîte
branchée de la capitale
fêtard et flambeur la nuit assassins de
vieilles dames le jour thierry paulin
dès son arrestation est entré dans la
galerie des grands criminels du xxème
siècle aux côtés des landes rue ede
petiau 18 assassinats de vieilles dames
commis entre 84 et 87 ont été attribués
à thierry paulin ses crimes en série
avait à l'époque provoqué une psychose
dans la région parisienne on avait alors
parlé d'un tueur de la pleine lune
repérant ses victimes sur les marchés
des esprits plus rationnelle assuré ne
s'agissait que de coïncidence et bien
non la réalité pour une fois à dépasser
la fiction décrit par ceux qui l'ont
approché comme un être inconscient
mythomane et amoral thierry paulin avait
stupéfait policiers et magistrats lors
de son arrestation en décembre 87 ils
tuent comme d'autres vont au bureau
avait confié un policier thierry paulin
ne sera jamais jugé l'ancien danseur de
cabaret est mort la nuit dernière à
l'hôpital de fresnes il s'appelle jean
thierry mathurin il a 26 ans son procès
s'ouvre demain à paris mathurin est au
coeur de l'une des plus grandes affaires
criminelles des dernières années ami de
thierry paulin décédé à la prison de
fresnes en 89 il est accusé de
complicité d'assassinât il serait
impliqué directement dans onze
agressions et huit meurtres de personnes
âgées dominique verdeilhan
d'abord l'objet convoité le porte
monnaie ensuite la silhouette frêle qui
laisse augurer une proie vulnérable des
femmes seules enfin la filature discrète
jusqu'au domicile seule une rencontre
pourrait arrêter l'irréparable les
escaliers le palier et une fois la porte
ouverte l'horreur torture coups de
ciseaux strangulation étouffement par
sac plastique absorption de liquide
vaisselle rue nicolet rue des trois
frères de 84 à 81 7 le même constat une
sauvagerie inouïe un appartement saccagé
la mort et le vol d'une somme d'argent
dérisoire le xviiie arrondissement
devient le périmètre de la peur face un
criminel insaisissable face à la
psychose les politiques se lance dans un
débat sécuritaire
nous assistons depuis des mois et des
mois à l'égard du ministre la terrière
pour qu'on arrête de nous raconter des
sornettes sur le plan du nombre de
policiers qui sont présents dans les
rues nous le savons bien qu'il n'y en a
pas les crimes ont été commis
semble-t-il et je te donne pas je ne
prends pas ça pour argent comptant ils
ont été commis à une période aussi bien
aux voiles octobre au mois de novembre
et la période de la pleine lune après
trois ans d'impuissance la police arrête
le coupable par hasard le commissaire
jacob identifie dans la rue le suspect
numéro un grâce un portrait robot
thierry paulin à 24 ans il avoue 24
assassinat et donne son ami jean thierry
mathurin ici en 86 deux ans après les
faits la nuit et la drogue sont leurs
univers une vie dissolue pour oublier
leur propre solitude et leur propre
dérive à la veille du procès la défense
constate que côté victimes c'est encore
le grand vide
je ne comprends pas qu à ce jour une
seule victime une femme victime
seulement se soient manifestés cela
constitue partie civile j'estime que
c'est un procès qui intéresse tout le
monde j'estime que le sort de ces
vieilles dames intéresse tout le monde
et que dans ce dossier l'on doit se
mobiliser
paulin est mort du sida en 89 et
mathurin reste seul avec ses onze
assassinat ignoble et le sordide
aujourd'hui devant la cour d'assises de
paris
jean-thierry mathurin est jugé pour le
meurtre de huit vieille dame mais ce
sera aussi le procès posthume de son
complice thierry paul à thierry paulin
mort du sida en prison était l'auteur
présumé de 27 meurtres de personnes
âgées l'audience d'aujourd'hui est donc
les pilotes de l'une des plus grandes
affaires criminelles du siècle même si
un seul des deux accusés étaient dans le
box cet après midi albert ripamonti
change me l'envoie
obéit sont soumis les gentils rim à
turin a aujourd'hui 26 ans il cherche à
faire bonne impression et répond
poliment aux questions il est plein de
bonne volonté
pourtant d'ailleurs ce sourire se cache
l'horreur les pièces à conviction sont
là pour en témoigner
lame de couteau pointe de ciseaux autant
d'instruments de torture dans les mains
de mathurin et de son compagnon thierry
paulin octobre novembre 84 une psychose
gagne le xviiie arrondissement de paris
8 vieille dame sont assassinés à leur
domicile
roué de coups violentes et l'une d'elles
mêmes forces et d'avaler de la soude
caustique pour avouer où se trouvent ces
économies car le vol est le mobile du
crime quelques centaines de francs voire
quelques milliers que paulin et mathurin
claque dans des boîtes homosexuel ou
pour se procurer de la drogue en
décembre 87 presque par hasard dans la
rue le commissaire jacob arrête thierry
paulin qui dénonce immédiatement son
complice mathurin jean-thierry mathurin
dans la vie se résume à ce seul mot la
galère un père alcoolique qui essaie de
le tuer violer à 7 ans par deux
légionnaires à kourou l'échec scolaire
la prostitution l'héroïne et sa
rencontre avec thierry paulin du jour où
je les ai vus affirme-t-il je suis
devenu son esclave sa victime mathurin
qui chargent paulin pour atténuer ses
responsabilités mais l'autre n'est plus
là pour se défendre il est mort du sida
en prison en 1989 devant les assises de
paris suite du procès de jean thierry
mathurin accusé du meurtre de huit
personnes âgées d'entrée mathurin a
chargé son complice thierry paulin qui
est mort du sida en prison en 1989 en
guise de défense ils rappellent
inlassablement qu'il a été la victime et
l'ex clave de paul un compte rendu
d'audience avec dominique verdeilhan et
jean-françois chevet
paulin est un fantôme et mathurin veut
rester son ombre mais à force de vouloir
se faire oublier mathurin en fait trop
lorsque le tribunal égrène les premières
agressions il offre toujours la même
réponse stéréotypé j'étais en arrière je
ne faisais que fouiller l'appartement
mathurin se donne le bon rôle de la
figuration qu'on ne peut guère qualifiée
d'intelligente qu'ils repéraient les
victimes paulin qui torturaient olemps
qui tu es paulin j'ai toujours agi à la
demande de paulin je n'avais pas le
choix défense facile et mesquine et peut
être dangereuse mathurin qui s'apitoie
sur son sort c'était tellement horrible
à vivre mais qui reste de marbre 2 les
victimes est absent quand une parente
raconte je n'ai pas eu le droit de voir
ma mère il avait mis le feu à
l'appartement des familles qui pensent
aussi à la récidive
ont décrit comme une sorte d'orphelins
tu n'aurais pas de père et qu'il aurait
trouvée en tirer paulin alors moi la
question que je me posais c est ce que
en sortant dans 20 ans par exemple
est-ce que s'il retrouve personne qui
pourrait ressembler à tirer paulhan
qu'est-ce qui se passera extra manière
comment c'est les même chose pour le
mobile il faut aller au delà du simple
appât du gain avance un psychiatre
paulin avait le mépris des femmes des
vieux un rejet de sa mère et de sa grand
mère olemps est un prédateur mathurin un
suiveur et on repense alors un détail
sordide l'emploi qu'occupe aujourd'hui
la mère de mathurin elle garde des
petites vieilles réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité assortie d'une peine
incompressible de 18 ans les jurés n'ont
accordé aucune circonstance atténuante à
jean thierry mathurin l'auteur de huit
meurtres de personnes âgées en 1984
l'accusé s'est effondré à l'annoncé du
verdict quelques heures auparavant un
avocat s'était écrié je cite j'espère
que dieu existe car lui seul peut lui
pardonner dominique verdeilhan un
verdict sans surprise sauf pour jean
thierry mathurin à l'énoncé de la
sentence après deux heures vingt de
délibéré
l'accusé s'est évanoui par trois fois ça
va monsieur mathurin a demandé sans rire
le président ferret mathurin avait bien
entendu les jurés l'ont condamné pour
huit assassinats sur les dix retenue et
ne lui ont reconnu aucune circonstance
atténuante verdict perpétuité avec 18
ans incompressibles
mon client ému qu'il était son trouble
lorsque le président prononcer le mot
peine de sûreté il a pensé qu'
effectivement il en allait dire qu'il
allait faire trente ans et quand il a
entendu 18 ans d'émotions il s'est
écoulé discrète et digne les parents de
deux victimes les seules parties civiles
du procès les seuls à avoir fait face à
mathurin durant quatre jours et avoir
sorti les personnes âgées de l'anonymat
ça fait quand même sept ans que les
victimes attendent ce jour là et que les
dossiers soient menés à la va vite comme
ça même si la plupart ont été reconnus
je crois que c'est très dommage et je
crois pour l'exemplarité c'est pas le
bon choix selon son avocat jean thierry
mathurin ne devrait pas se pourvoir en
cassation ne souhaitant pas prendre le
risque d'une condamnation plus forte
mathurin ne sera pas libéré avant 2010
il aura alors 43 ans mais d'abord
l'actualité judiciaire avec une
libération celle de jean thierry
mathurin son nom vous est peut être
inconnu il était le complice d'un des
tueurs en série les plus redoutables de
ces dernières années thierry paulin
qu'on appelait le tueur de vieilles
dames jean-thierry mathurin condamné à
la perpétuité pour sept meurtres est
sortie aujourd'hui de la prison de
poissy après 22 ans de détention orolia
guillemin eric de l'agneau 18 ans se
sont écoulés depuis ces images
jean-thierry mathurin les a passés
derrière les barreaux 22 ans de prison
au total pour le complice de thierry
paulin surnommé le tueur de vieilles
dames l'afer a marqué les esprits entre
1984 et 1987 les deux hommes s'aiment la
psychose dans les rues du xviiie
arrondissement de paris les victimes des
dames âgées qu'ils suivent jusque chez
elle ligotent torturent et tuent à
l'époque thierry paulin arrêté par
hasard à vous une vingtaine de meurtres
mais il décède du sida deux ans plus
tard sans avoir été jugé
mathurin se retrouve seul au procès
condamné pour huit assassinats il écope
de la prison à perpétuité dont 18 ans
incompressibles il a pu être libéré ce
matin sous le régime de la semi-liberté
ce que j'ai fait avec jean thierry
mathurin senet appliquer la loi nous
avions une possibilité de sortir autour
d'un projet d'un projet construit dès
lors que ce projet a été présenté et a
convaincu les juges c'est son droit de
sortir quasiment illettrés lors de son
incarcération jean-thierry mathurin a
obtenu un bep en prison et s'apprête à
travailler pour une entreprise de
retraitement des déchets électriques il
n'est pour l'instant qu'en liberté
conditionnelle mais aspire à une vie
discrète loin du monde de la nuit de la
drogue qu'il fréquentait au moment des
faits
[Musique]